now gross profit amounts to your total
revenue minus your cost of goods sold
so that's answer B cost of goods sold
may also be a new term for you and this
refers to the costs associated with
making your product for example say your
business is selling water bottles and
this is a water bottle I promise now you
sell these water bottles for $19.99 but
it costs you $5.00 and sixty cents to
make them your cost of goods sold is
then this five dollars and sixty cents
and when you subtract that from your
total revenue per water bottle you get a
remainder of 14 dollars and 13 cents
also known as your gross profit per
water bottle net profit is then your
total revenue after subtracting all of
your expenses as an operating business
now keep in mind that this can easily be
a net loss and your goal is to implement
a mono station model that keeps your
numbers positive